ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show uh we are here a very good
friend uh director actor writer Eli Roth
thank you for having me I know it's a
rare occasion it's a rare occasion
um for a guest on the show there's very
few and most of them are hated well I'm
a listener to the Pod so yeah I hate
when you have guests because I tune in
to listen to you rant so I know how
people feel hearing my voice yeah and
I'll just say this don't kill sharks
thanks Tim no but here's why I wanted to
have you on very rarely do I want to
talk to someone about something then I'm
looking at your Instagram and I'm I'm
just seeing bloody sharks bloody fish
and I'm looking at this and I'm going is
everything okay can you communicate to
me why at some point in your life you
decided to care about vicious killing
machines that inhabit our oceans
well thank you for that lovely
introduction Tim I I agree